my lord richard dannet is uh with us now
former chief of the general staff of
course um hello my lord thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
what's your interpretation of what's
happening in ukraine at the moment
well okay we are witnessing some uh
incredible scenes
um the russians undoubtedly have
suffered a significant setback and the
ukrainians have been pretty clever in in
what they've been doing if you remember
over the last few weeks we've been
talking a lot about a possible
counter-offensive in the south around
the area of curson and everyone took
that seriously indeed there had been
counter-offensive moves uh in the south
but it was played up to be the big
counter-offensive such that the russians
deployed some of their better troops
away from the north to counter this a
potential counter-offensive in the south
but in fact what the ukrainians had in
mind all along was actually this major
attack not in the south but actually in
the north in the kharkiv area and that's
what they have unfolded dramatically and
very successfully uh in the in the last
few days and they've pulled off an
operational level surprise um quite a
significant thing to be able to do
result of that is that the russians have
pretty much turned and fled in that area
of ukraine um cupianze which was one of
their major logistic hubs has fallen
many of the railway tracks um bringing
supplies in to the russians converge in
that part of the world and indeed the
town of israel as well they've both
fallen
and this is a significant reverse for
the russians a great success for the
ukrainians and as president zielenski is
saying um they'll do more but they
continue to need more and more western
arms and ammunition in order to be able
to keep the pressure up but tell them
it's been no doubt that this is a
significant uh improvement in the
circumstances great for the people that
um deborah was just talking to but um if
you just look at the map um although the
ukrainians have made significant
advances there's a lot of their country
still in russian occupation um so
there's a long way to go
yeah and as far as the blackouts are
concerned that we've been hearing about
that can cause no end of problems not
only for civilians but also for the
military
well
of course you're right but what we're
seeing is the russians reacting in their
typically heavy-handed way
they know that they've had a significant
reverse on the battlefield so they're
lashing out in other ways to to try and
restore their position
and the attack on the power station
which has reduced that part of the
kharkiv area to darkness uh is a typical
example of them blindly lashing out with
everything they possibly can to try and
reassert themselves but but i think
experience shows looking right back
through history that if you're trying to
win a war by cowing the opposition's
public it just doesn't work
and the resistance and the attitude that
you're seeing from the ukrainian people
is yes no we don't like the darkness we
don't like the lack of water but we will
win through
they will not break our spirit
and i think that is the other critical
issue morale in ukraine morale amongst
the ukrainian forces is sky high when
amongst the russian forces it is
terribly low
and turning and running and fleeing base
hospitals being overrun being evacuated
i mean this is these are signs of well i
was going to say an army in panic
certainly an army in disarray and putin
and his senior generals have got a real
problem to know how to stabilize the
area um in the north they'll do it
because their numbers are such that they
will but um
there's no getting away from the fact
they've suffered a major reverse at the
present moment
uh but putin is i suppose potentially it
is most dangerous when he is cornered
and thus the same for his army
you're right and i think you're probably
suggesting um the question of
will he up the ante um possibly even in
a nuclear way well
i would like
fervently hope that he will not do that
i think he has other options
um he's always called this a special
military operation and has tried to use
in-place forces he has got the option if
he thinks politically he could get away
with it by declaring war
with the change to regulations and
change the law in
russia that that would bring whereby he
could bring in conscription he could
start to mobilize other parts of the
russian military to try and stabilize
the front but um
there's great political risks in him
doing that so far he's managed to
contain what the russian people know
about this appalling
operation that he began
but if he goes down
down the track
of calling it a war
fully mobilizing his country bringing in
conscription then the political stakes
for him become increasingly high and
maybe he won't do that
president zelinski has said the next
three months are critical as we head
into the winter time would you agree
with him
uh yes i think actually every day is
critical every week is critical at the
present moment um the period of maneuver
can continue during what's an
increasingly wet period on the ground
and then as we get closer to the end of
the year uh the temperatures will drop
the ground will freeze
and that'll make conditions very
difficult but it does actually mean that
degree of movement can start again but
um
i think those circumstances are such
that i would expect to see continuing
movement now
and then probably the war going into a
fairly period of stasis over the worst
of the winter and then we'll see what
happens again next spring
because the russians have been trying to
amass a larger force
they've been putting together something
called the third army corps
which is a force that they're trying to
recruit and train and we're hoping to
put back into the field next spring
because of the pressure on them they've
had to put some of those units already
into the field probably only partially
trained so
the thing is spiraling out of beauty
into control
um as i say i think we'll see more
movement in the next few weeks probably
slowing down during the heart of the
winter and then maybe the day new more
next spring
before i let you go um my lord a thought
on the passing of the queen what impact
does it have uh on the military when
there is a new
sovereign
well it has impact on all of us in the
country but i think it has a particular
impact on members of the armed forces um
much has been made of the fact that when
we join the army navy air force or
whatever um
we sign we we swear an oath of
allegiance and i did that on the 28th of
august 1969 a long time ago now and that
oath of allegiance was to queen
elizabeth ii but actually the uh phrase
also her heirs and successors were part
of that oath so seamlessly when the
queen breathed her last last thursday
our allegiance as soldiers of the queen
we immediately became soldiers of the
king and that's a very special link that
the military have we carry out
operations at risk of life and limb not
in the name of the government or the
prime minister or the secretary of state
for defense we do it in the name of the
sovereign and the people of this country
that's a very special link a very
special bond actually i think it makes
the british armed forces themselves
pretty special as a result
indeed so my lord thank you so much for
taking the time to join us on the
program this morning thank you thank you